summer blockbuster season is here and
new trailers are being released nearly
every day it's hard to keep up with the
constant influx of epic footage so we've
compiled a handy list here's a rundown
of all the trailers released in May that
will absolutely blow you away this
summer and beyond
okhta snowpiercer director bong joon-ho
partnered with Netflix for okiya a movie
with an all-star cast and a deep message
about environmental protection the
studio finally released the full trailer
earlier this month
showing off the movies gorgeous visuals
and it's absolutely perhaps like a young
girl attempting to rescue her pet super
pig named oak jump before an evil
corporation can turn it into food Jake
Gyllenhaal Paul Dana Tilda Swinton and
Giancarlo Esposito also show up in the
trailer which promises a unique thrill
ride from start to finish
check it out On June 28 the house
starring Will Ferrell and Amy Poehler as
to parents who open up an underground
casino to fill up their daughters
college fund the house makes an early
bid for the summer's broadest comedy and
if the film's red band trailer is any
indication they're quick money scheme
doesn't go as smoothly as they hoped
look for all the high-octane hijinks
under 30 spider-man I'm coming the final
trailer so spider-man homecoming really
sets this reboot apart from the previous
Spidey films we get more glimpses of the
cool tech the Tony Stark built into
Peters suit including his own version of
Java's you know 500 only hit population
abomination bike path trailers this
footage highlights how much Tony wants
Peter to quit crime-fighting but those
are offers some fun glimpses of Tony as
a mentor this dynamic will prove crucial
once Spidey gets started Michael
Keaton's vulture is a terrifying villain
for young pakka to start off against so
you probably need a lot of help from
Iron Man finally it gives us our best
look yet at Donnell gloves mysterious
character swing in to see it on July 7
war for the Planet of the Apes the final
trailer thought war for the planet of
Dax proves the movie isn't pulling any
punches in the escalating war between
man and a there's a heavy emphasis on
the differences between anti circuses
Caesar and Woody Harrelson's ruthless
Colonel setting up the humans as savages
rather than the Apes the trailer also
features a heavy dose of Steves and bad
ape a new character who seems destined
could become a fan favorite the trailer
promises no mercy and no peace and an
epic violent showdown to take the
franchise to the next level on July 14
the big sick this isn't your typical
rom-com the big six stars Silicon Valley
is Kumail Nanjiani who co-wrote the
script alongside his wife Emily B Gordon
based on the true story of how they met
and fell in love but the biggest problem
is one most couples never have to
experience shortly into their courtship
emily falls into a coma it's a
rollercoaster of emotions and the movies
early reviews suggest Nanjiani and
gordon hit them in all the right places
the big sick has a June 23rd release day
Dunkirk
Christopher Nolan is a master of
suspense and he's proved it again with
the second trailer for his upcoming war
thriller Dunkirk starring Tom Hardy
Killian Murphy in Kenneth Branagh and
former One Direction singer Harry Styles
in the story of the 1940 evacuation of
the French city of Dunkirk where
thousands of soldiers were left stranded
on a beach surrounded by enemy forces
the trailer definitely gets viewers
pulses pounding successfully ramping up
anticipation for an intense fast-paced
experience unlike any war film you've
seen before check it out July 21st
velaryon the final trailer for the
upcoming sci-fi thriller DeLorean and
the city of a thousand planets doesn't
give away much of the plot instead
focusing on the film's incredible
visuals choosing a feast for the eyes
when the movie hits the big screen on
July 21st
valerian won't just be all digital
thrills though based on a French
graphics novel which also heavily
influenced the visuals of director
Luc Besson's the Fifth Element valerian
tells a hell of a story following two
time-traveling agents tasked with saving
the planet alpha from a mysterious
all-consuming threat Clive Owen John
Goodman Ethan Hawke and Rihanna also pop
up in the project which promises to be
another hit sci-fi action film for the
Fifth Element director The Dark Tower
inspired by Stephen King's best-selling
saga of the same name this adaptations
been many many years in the making but
the first trailer suggests that time
might have been just what filmmakers
needed to get the story right the
trailer is almost all action from start
to finish
starting with an intense dream
experienced by young Jake chambers one
which foreshadows a journey into a
visually stunning world grounded by
impressive performances by idris elba
and Matthew McConaughey the dark hours
trailer doesn't give much away instead
offering just enough to leave viewers
champing at the bit for the film's
release on August 4 Wind River Avenger
star Jeremy Renner and Elizabeth Olsen
play very different kinds of heroes in
the upcoming thrill of Wind River when
they're tasked with hunting down a
killer in the icing wilderness of the
Wind River Indian Reservation we're
ready for a thrilling intense ride when
Wind River arrives on August 4 good time
from a 24 the indie studio behind get
out good time stars Robert Pattinson as
Connie a man on a mission to get his
mentally handicapped brother Nick out of
jail after their attempted bank robbery
goes awry Pattinson is electric in the
trailer and early reviews are calling
this his best performance yet and what
looks to be one of the most intense and
beautiful thrillers released in recent
years good time hit Studios August 11
the hit man's bodyguard the first
trailer for the hit man's body God gave
us a lot of action and swearing but the
newest preview dose deeper into the
film's story and gives us a glimpse of
Gary Oldman as the ruthless villain it
also teaches more of the bickering
partnership between Ryan Reynolds and
well Jackson's characters 27 times
that's how many times I tried to kill me
24 28 putting these two together
promises the potential for one of the
summers most explosive comedies look for
it August 18
Logan lucky Elms by acclaimed writer
director Steven Soderbergh Logan lucky
is an action comedy starring Channing
Tatum and Adam driver as brothers who
decide to rob the coca-cola 600 one of
the biggest races of the year with the
help of inmates Jo bang played with
gusto by Daniel Craig and in car sir
gray and this one 80s inspired trailer
uses bright images and upbeat score and
a lot of one-liners to convince viewers
to race out to the theater on August 18
it stains the sand red horror thriller
it stains the sand red follows a woman
stuck in the desert pursued by an
untiring member of the undead and the
trailer promises a picture that flips
the genre on its head and make tied
tropes actually scary again leave the
lights on when you check out the trailer
and prepare to be left on the edge of
your seat waiting for this indie
thriller to scare its way into theaters
this summer it it is scared of clowns
the second trailer the Stephen King's it
is definitely not for you the terror
ramps up quickly with a tiny horrifying
glimpse of Pennywise the clown bill
skarsgård plays penny wise and he's
scaring an impressive cast of
experienced child actors including st.
Vincent's Jaden Lieber her and stranger
things in wolfhard
as the trailer shows it isn't short on
suspense or all our scarce and it seems
like a safe bet to be the horror hit of
the fall when it hits theaters on
September I would shock another
potential hit from the studio behind get
out would shock stars Kirsten Dunst as a
woman who tries a drug that triggers
hallucinations the trailer uses haunting
music to show the inner workings of
Dancing's character who appears to be
hiding a dark secret this tribute clip
opens on a typically dramatic
but quickly moves into the insane
getting stranger as it goes on get ready
for a trip on September 15
Blade Runner 20:49 if you've been
nervous about the upcoming Blade Runner
sequel this trailer should calm your
fears the trailer offers a glimpse of
the world entrenched in the culture of
the first film and the results are so
gorgeous and action-packed that it's
impossible to look away even more
impressive it does all this without
giving away too much of the movie's plot
so feast your eyes and don't worry about
the spoilers chances are we'll get quite
a few surprises when the film finally
arrives on October 6 thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]